[موسيقى]
اعلن يا الجيش الكوري الجنوبيه نشر 80
مقاتله بعضها من طراز اف 35 ردا على اجراء
الممثلين من كوريا الشماليه وكانت صول قد
اعلنت في وقت سابق رصد تحركي نحوي 100 و
180 طائره حربيه كوريا شماليه في المجال
الجوي لبيونغ ويتزامل التوتر في شبه جزيره
الكوريه مع مناورات جويه بين الولايات
المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه هي الاكبر في
تاريخ العلاقات بين البلدين
نجاه ثانيه قالت كوريا الجنوبيه ان الجيش
الكوري الشمالي اطلق نحو 80 قذيفه مدفعيه
على المنطقه الحدوديه البحريه بين البلدين
وخلال اجتماع في واشنطن تعاهد وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لويد اوستن ونظيره الكوري
الجنوبيه
جديده ردا على ما وصفها بالاستفزازات
الكوريه الشماليه المتكرره وحذر اوستن من
ان اي هجوم نووي على الولايات المتحده او
حلفائها وشركائها سوف يتسبب في نهايه نظام
وكانت سول قد اكدت ان كوريا الشماليه
اطلقت الخميس صاروخا باليسيا عابرا
للقارات ورجحه ان تكون العمليه قد بائت
بالفشل وقالت هيئه الاركان الكوريه
الجنوبيه الصاروخ قطع 760 كيلو مترا
تقريبا على ارتفاع نحو الفن 1920 كم لكنه
فشل على ما يبدو في المرحله الثانيه من
عمليه انفصال الصاروخ
نقلت وكاله رويترز عن مسؤول رفيع في
الاداره الامريكيه قوله ان واشنطن ترغب في
ان تستخدم الصين وروسيا نفوذهما لاقناع
كوريا الشماليه بعدم استئناف تجارب
القنبله النوويه واضاف ان المسؤولين
الامريكيين ليس لديهم توقيت واضح بشان
التجربه النوويه المقبله لبيونغ كما كشف
المسؤول لوكاله رويترز ان الولايات
المتحده ساعات للتواصل مع كوريا الشماليه
عبر قنوات خاصه ومن خلال اطراف ثالثه كما
ان واشنطن ترفض تعامل المجتمع الدولي مع
كوريا الشماليه باعتبارها قوه نوويه
كما افادت وكاله رويترز بان الولايات
المتحده واليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه بصدد
استكمال الترتيبات لعقد لقاء قمه بين قاده
البلدان الثلاثه في منتصف في الشهر الجاري
واشارت الوكاله الى ان المحادثات ستجرى
على هامشي مؤتمر دوليا من المقرر عقده في
جنوب شرق اسيا
ما بين الثاني والثالث من نوفمبر الجاري
اطلقت كوريا الشماليه عدد من الصواريخ
البالستيه ليصبح العام الفان 2022 عاما
قياسيه للتجارب الصاروخيه لكوريا الشماليه
يحدث ذلك في اجواء من التوتر تخيم على شبه
الجزيره الكوريه في الثلاثين من يناير
الماضي اجره كوريا الشماليه اكبر تجربه
صاروخيه لها مدعمي 2017 باطلاق اقوى صاروخ
في ترسلتها محلقا على ارتفاع 2000 كيلو
متر قبل ان يسقط في بحر اليابان
وصلت
تجاربها الصاروخيه من فئه لاخرى ومن اين
باخرى وصولا الى قرارها اللافت حين تبنت
في سبتمبر الماضي قانون يخولها تنفيذ ضربه
نوويه وقائيه واعلانات ان وضعها كقوه
نوويه امر لا رجوع فيهما يعني انها انهاء
المفاوضات بشان برامجها المسلحه
المحظوره عقب هذا القرار ابدت الولايات
المتحده دعمها لكوريا الجنوبيه واعادت
حامله الطائرات رونالدو التي تعمل بطاقه
نوويه ومجموعه السفن المرافقه الى شبه
الجزيره الكوريه في السادس والعشرين من
الشهر ذاته بدات الولايات المتحده وكوريا
الجنوبيه مناورات بحريه على الساحل الشرقي
لكوريا الجنوبيه شامله سفنا ومجموعه
متنوعه من الطائرات لمحاكاه عمليات
الحربيه مضاده للسفن والغواصات ومناورات
تكتيكيه في مطلع اكتوبر قالت ان السلسله
تجاربها الصاروخيه الاخيره هدفها محاكاه
استهداف كوريا الجنوبيه بوابل من الاسلحه
النوويه التكتيكيه اواخر اكتوبر بدات
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه احد
اكبر التدريبات الجويه العسكريه المشتركه
بينهما بمشاركه نحو 240 طائره حربيه ورده
كوريا الشماليه بالتهديد باستخدام السلاح
النووي وجولات من القصف المدعي